will the last man on earth escape the TV
sci-fi comedy curse I have the answer on
this week's episode of angry nerd first
your comments 80 jamming rights can you
talk about Netflix's upcoming Legend of
Zelda show hey all's I know for sure
about it at this point is that it's
going to be better than the zelda CDI
games yeah that'll get it's no match for
the king I can't wait to bomb some
dodongos what was up with that how is
that a thing so will forte's new series
last man on earth is like a funny take
on I am legend but with no vampire
zombies now I'm a sucker for the man
alone sub-genre of sideline because it
can be bleak and funny at the same like
Charlton Heston and omega man
lip-syncing along with a movie scene 100
times or when Bruno Lawrence cracks up
and declares himself planetary president
in the quieter is it not picking them
that I be president of this quiet or
that episode of Twilight Zone where
burgess Meredith is finally alone with
all of the books and he's eager to read
and he breaks his glasses ah that scene
always makes you want to duct-tape my
glasses to my noggin anyway I really
like the dry laugh track for humor of
last man on earth you can tell it was
produced by the genius comedy team Lord
Miller who made 21 Jump Street and the
Lego by the way how effed up is it that
the lego movie didn't get an Oscar last
man on earth is also a nice change of
pace for most American sci-fi comedy
series think about it the biggest hits
are always the broadest silliest lowest
common denominator eous stuff Alf my
favorite Martian Mork and Mindy third
Rock from the Sun I mean none of them
are that different from a family matters
episode where or makes a bizarre can
the Brits have a much higher class of
sci-fi comedy I think it's partly the
influence of Doctor Who which could
never really take itself too seriously
because the effects were so laughable
the UK gave us Hitchhiker's Guide to the
galaxy by Doctor Who alum Douglas Adams
red dwarf hyperdrive 2.4 children
goodnight sweetheart no heroics all
we're seeking out all light years beyond
Alf the closest we get to gut-busting
science fiction on TV in America are
sci-fi channel monster movies yeah I
don't care what you say sharknado is
overrated it's all about mega shark vs
crocosaurus but I demand to see more
American TV sci-fi that's hilarious on
purpose and cut it was that last take
okay do we need to redo it hey whatever
one go hello hello they're all gone I'm
the last man on earth hello at last I
finally have the time to read my backlog
of comics with no interruptions like I
finally what so fair it's not fair it's
not fun hey I don't care if the Korean
taco truck is going by don't leave me
alone on this set again what do you
think of last man on earth and what's
your favorite sci-fi comedy series
American or otherwise let me know in the
comments subscribe to the wire channel
and click on these other videos to watch
more of my rants if you don't click
those other versions of me will just be
stuck sitting there alone cut off from
humanity gradually driven insane by the
oppressive solitude
what you're still not clicking oh you
heartless monster how can you live with
yourself you know I'll bet your top ten
desert island dvds are all Michael Bay
movies